I thought I said King crap for a second
I was like well I know what that is
that's a giant I'm kind of excited
because I'm a big fan of kpop is it kind
of like in k-pop songs they start
singing in English and in Korean it's a
language from the Congo am i right
I do not know any of these I am not
Korean as many of you guys don't know
kinship makes me immediately think of
pork maybe you're saying someone looks
like a pig a friend you have a
relationship with that you give them
some skin a lot it's a relationship that
you have with your skin way you treat
your skin the way you care for your
skins when you ship skin dry skin moist
skin done
[Music]
how'd you get into skinship I might
actually take that into my own
vocabulary King car king sized car like
Oh duh your car as a king car King Kong
this is the giant monkey that takes over
New York City
[Music]
King no it's not true okay I call people
that will Korean people like be like oh
this girl knows all about us stuff now I
have a new pickup line hey you're a king
car selca self-care science and
engineering library in California yes
so call like a selfie I kind of like
that better than selfie SNS sounds like
something dirty and sexual solid no
sleeves say no sir SNSD is a popular
Korean pop band so not sorry
BAM oh my hit you up on that SNS CF ter
forever this is the k-pop group okay so
we have a F I'm tired
see app because I'm tired cos clown face
yeah chubby friends so I would be like
Oh have you seen that CF with the girl
eating the Apple song apart apartheid
how much of a distance is there between
you or you were torn apart out of the
Korean accent oh I'll put two apothem in
ha boom
[Music]
we're going back to my part girl i'ma
show you how I'll is fighting is it like
fighting the urge to do something bad
let's start a fight I know this one
there watch a lot of kdrama like it just
means like in Chinese is like die oh go
let's do this
hey dramas man they get your heart it
Mickey wanted white these are kind of
fun I really want to adopt some of these
into my own vernacular fighting is the
best word cuz it's encouragement anybody
can use it it's English it's green
konglish I also like skinship because
it's what I'd like to do with all of the
King cars of the world I'm going to
invite them to my parts we're gonna take
a self-cam we're gonna add each other
and everything's me great